Hãy bỏ trận động đất sảy ra vào lúc 1 xong giờ năm sau khúc nè,
20% hong giờ địa phương,
tại quân đạo thuật khara,
với trận động năm phải 1% sâu tâm trận 2,5 km,
đây là dung trận thương năm 2018,
chỉ trong vòng tảm nề qua tại khu bực này.
Trong chưa quân ngày từ 1,5 mỡi giờ đến 1 bài giờ,
đã có thêm xong trận động đất từ lối mạnh.
Cơ quan khi tưởng như bạn cho biết,
hiện chưa phát hiện quyết cơ sống tàn,
cũng như chưa ghi nhận thử thải bên người và tài sản.
Tuy nhiên, tần xuống dài đặc mắm độ,
bắt thường của các dùng trận đang kiến người dật lòng ai.
Đà biển nhu ý kiến chuyên gia tình báo,
cần theo dõi sát,
vì khu vực cho khó ra tình ghi nhận,
có chủ đậm đất quy mô,
vào các năm 2018,
không trọng em mốt và hành em phục trọng em ba.
Trưa dây biển này,
cái điều phương đàn tình nhá phương án,
sơ tàn sống,
cơ sân,
trên bày hòn đạo có người xin sống.
Một số nhà hoa cũng tình báo sàng,
khi tưởng địa trên này có thể là giấu hiệu tích tụng năng lượng tiêm ẩn,
cho một chạm đậm đất lượng hơn.